bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
sur Public Sénat à suivre cet après-midi
en direct les auditions d'Emmanuel
Macron ministre de l'économie ainsi que
celle de Carole Delga secrétaire d'État
au Commerce tous deux sont auditionnés
par les sénateurs de la commission des
affaires économiques du Sénat
sur les crédits accordés à leur
ministère par le projet de loi de
finances 2015 Emmanuel Macron le
ministre de l'économie s'est récemment
illustré notamment en réclamant la fin
des retraites chapeau ces compléments de
rémunération très généreux qui peuvent
être accordé à certains anciens
dirigeants également en s'attaquant aux
professions réglementées notairire
huissier ou encore avocat rappelons que
le projet de loi de finances pour 2015 a
été adopté en PR première lecture hier
par l'Assemblée nationale et cela malgré
certaines voix socialistes qui se sont
élevés pour dénoncer une politique
économique trop favorable aux
entreprises et pas assez au ménages et
aux investissements publics on prend
tout de suite donc la direction de la
salle
micis écoutez nous allons vous entendre
sur les crédits de votre
ministère vous occupez monsieur le
ministre ses fonctions depuis depuis peu
de temps pour autant vous n'êtes pas un
nouveau nous avions reçu votre
prédécesseur le 3 juin dernier il nous
avait d'ailleurs annoncé une série de
d'initiatives de mesures qu'il
souhaitait prendre notamment dans le
domaine des professions réglementées et
nous avions ét les premiers à l'entendre
et je vais vous confier une chose
pension que c'était une allez petite
provocation de sa
part pas un exercice un peu solitaire
sur le sujet et finalement on a vu que
le sujet non non pas du tout il était
euh inspiré par une volonté
gouvernementale dont vous êtes
aujourd'hui le
porteur donc nous allons euh assez
rapidement connaître je crois que le
Conseil des ministres doit l'adopter
mi-décembre le projet de loi qui
va essayer de stimuler la croissance et
en même temps de rendre du pouvoir
d'achat aux consommateurs notamment avec
cette réforme des des professions
réglementées alors nous souhaiterions
monsieur le ministre que vous livriez
à un exercice qui nous permett de voir
quels sont les points de continuité avec
votre prédécesseur également les points
d'inflexion entre votre action et et
celle qu'a mené votre prédécesseur et
surtout nous souhaitons connaître de
votre part quelles sont les orientations
quel est le calendrier du futur projet
de loi sur l'économie auquel votre nom
sera associé alors vous avez des
contraintes d'oraire que nous allons
bien sûr respecter vous avez on va dire
une bonne heure il faut que vous partiez
à à 17h45 vous m'avez dit en arrivant
faut que je parte à 45 je dis oh là bon
il reste quelques minutes mais non
heureusement il faut être positif hein
bon alors nous aurons ensuite à voir
madame la ministre en charge du Commerce
Artisanat petites entreprises et CEA
donc je réserve mon propos vous
concernant nous allons d'abord nous
consacrer à la partie qui sera occupée
par Monsieur Emmanuel Macron monsieur le
ministre nous vous écoutons
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs bonjour
ce que je propose c'est peut-être de
prendre une dizaine de minutes pour
essayer de donner un peu le le le cadre
de l'action ministère vous m'invitez à
parler aussi des crédits budgétaires
donc je vais essayer de faire cet
exercice de la manière la plus
englobante mais en même temps pour
donner le le sens général de l'action
que je compte conduire étant entendu que
c'est à mes yeux un premier échange que
j'ai avec votre commission parce que je
souhaite qu'on puisse le plus
régulièrement possible échanger au fond
il y aura ce projet de loi que vous
évoquez mais l'action de ce ministère je
la conçois aussi dans un dialogue alors
ce que je vous propose c'est peut-être
d'essayer d'avoir une perspective non
pas cinématographique mais de partir des
territoires puis de la politique
française et je finirai par la politique
européenne en élargissant
progressivement langue qui est donné
parce que c'est me semble-t-il la
continuité et la cohérence d'un fil que
nous devons trouver et on ne peut pas
avoir une bonne politique économique
sur le plan local si elle n'est pas
cohérente avec les ambitions que nous
portons sur le plan européen et avoir en
quelque sorte la même exigence alors
premier plan ce sont les territoires et
donc nos entreprises et à cet égard vous
m'invitiez à clarifier les aspects de
continuité avec mon prédécesseur je
tiens à dire qu' un travail important
que mon prédécesseur ses équipes avaient
fait et tout le ministère en terme de
défense du tissu industriel français et
je compte j'ai d'ailleurs pris des
dispositions pour le faire dès les
premières semaines poursuivre ce travail
dans un esprit de continuité ce qui veut
dire consolider le rôle des commissaires
au redressement productif qui font un
travail important depuis 2 ans sur les
territoires auprès des préfets avec plus
de 2000 dossiers différents parce que
c'est la responsabilité de l'État sur
les territoires au côté des régions et
de tous les acteurs locaux parce que
nous les voyons en particulier au
cabinet sous toute leur forme et dans
toute leur
composantes travailler au côté des
entreprises pour
pouvoir préserver leur activité sauver
tout ou partie de leur activité
lorsqu'elles sont menacées donc
consolidation du dispositif existant je
prendrai dans les prochaines semaines
une circulaire pour justement davantage
ancrer le rôle de ces commissaires
redressement productif dans le travail
de la Direction Générale des Entreprises
et en leur donnant aussi un rôle je
dirais mieux coordonné avec les
différents services de l'État sur le
plan financier également on peut
fluidifier nos instruments sur le plan
local mieux mobiliser être d'AV avantage
dans dans l'anticipation je vous
redonnerai sur ce sujet les détails si
vous le souhaitez mais c'est en tout cas
ma ma volonté volontarisme donc de cette
action sur le terrain et sur le front
défensif ce qui ne veut pas dire courir
après toutes les situations je veux
clarifier ce point de méthode mais se
battre derrière chaque situation qui en
vaut la peine et il y a beaucoup
d'entreprises que nous pouvons
aujourd'hui redresser dont nous ne
pouvons nous résoudre qu'ell se ferment
lorsqu'elles ont encore un marché encore
une produ viable néanmoins il y a aussi
une pédagogie à faire lorsque ce marché
n'existe plus ou qu'il n'y a pas de
possibilité de de reprise et donc c'est
pourquoi je ne considère pas que l'aide
aux entreprises en difficulté si elle
doit être un terrain d'engagement
politique administratif doit pas être
pour autant un un sujet primordial
d'action médiatique en quelque sorte et
mon cabinet fait un travail important
j'ai gardé la cellule qu'avait constitué
Arnaud mondbourg les CRP le Siri que
vous conna niss à Bery travaille mais il
travaille dans un esprit de de
discrétion de volontarisme et de
lucidité tel que je l'ai évoqué la
responsabilité de l'État c'est aussi de
fixer un cap en fonction des des
spécificités des territoires et ça a été
le sens de plusieurs initiatives qui ont
été portées je veux en citer en
particulier une ici qui est la
labellisation des métropoles frenchtech
neuf au total qui sont intervenus la
semaine dernière reconnaissant les
écosystèmes entrepreneuriauuxx qui se
sont structurés dans nos territoires il
faut également si je peis dire s'occuper
du quotidien parce que l'action
économique de notre ministère c'est
aussi le quotidien de notre économie et
des emplois on parle du front défensif
celui que je viens de détailler
quotidien c'est aussi les PME les
artisans qui ont des difficultés
sectorielles le BTP en est un bon
exemple et je laisserai Carole Delga
revenir sur ce sujet il y a plusieurs
initiatives qui seront conduites dans
les prochaines semaines prochains mois
et surtout un travail important que
Carole conduit à destiné de l'artisanat
du commerce qui structure notre tissu
économique et qui fait partie également
de notre compétitivité de l'activité au
quotidien de nos concitoyens enfin dans
nos territoires il faut également
préparer l'avenir en pariant sur les
entrepreneurs car dans l'économie où
nous trouvons qui une économie de
l'innovation vous avez dû en parler avec
Monsieur Tyrol ce sont les entrepreneurs
qui sont porteurs de croissance et
d'emploi les star les start-up pardon
représentent près de la moitié des
créations d'entreprises en France et ce
que je veux c'est qu'on puisse
accompagner ce mouvement aller plus loin
la Bpi en particulier consacrera 20
millions d'euros dès 2015 à la Bourse
frenchtech en ce sens mais c'est une
action que je compte développer parce
que les start-ups ça n'est pas
contrairement aux idées reçues que pour
quelques quartiers ou quelques endroits
du territoire français la labellisation
frenchtech que j'évoqué le montre mais
c'est un avant-post de notre économie
qu'il faut encourager qu'il faut
développer parce que cette nouvelle
économie doit de plus en plus aussi
travailler je n'aime pas ce terme mais
avec la vieille économie ou l'économie
classique et c'est tout ce que je veux
promouvoir en particulier ce qui me
permet de euh de faire le lien avec avec
ce point avec tout le volet offensif de
notre politique industrielle à travers
les 34 plans qui ont été mis en place
par mon prédécesseur sous l'impulsion du
du président de la République ces 34
plans ce sont 34 objectifs en quelque
sorte d'arriver au marché avec des
nouveaux produits avec des projets
industriels ils sont portés par des
industriels et donc c'est une initiative
qui vient en plus de ce qui a pu exister
déjà avec le Conseil national de de
l'industrie et avec la volonté
accompagné par l' par l'État pardon de
d'associer PME et Grands Groupes
partenaires publics et partenaires
privés pour arriver à des projets très
concret le le véhicule consommant les 2
L au
100 des drones pour citer des produits
d'actualité des innovations dans le
numérique par exemple euh avec des
innovations précisément dans le
traitement des données de masse des
innovations dans la transition
énergétique dans le véhicule comme je l'
évoqué à l'instant 34 plans couvrent
beaucoup de nos de nos secteurs
industriel aucun quasiment n'est
délaissé et j'ai eu l'occasion là aussi
de le dire je commencerai dans les
prochaines semaines une revue de ces 34
plans par famille par cohérence en
commençant par le numérique puis en
continuant par les les autres grandes
familles le l'automobile aussi très
bientôt pour essayer de regarder dans un
esprit très pragmatique ce qui marche ce
qui ne marche pas ce qui peut avoir des
synergies on peut rapprocher parce
qu'avoir 34 priorités c'est beaucoup
nous avons connu ça avec les pôles de
compétitivité c'est un peu la maladie
française quand on a trop de priorité
c'est qu'on a plus de priorité donc il
ne s'agit pas de couper des crédits je
veux le dire ici tout les crédits prévus
pour les 34 plans seront préservés mais
il s'agit de créer d'abord d'avoir une
approche pragmatique de créer plus de
transversalité entre les plans existants
parce que l'économie de l'innovation
dont je parle est une économie qui a
besoin de transversalité il faut pas
recréer des silos et c'est aussi de
créer plus d'internationalisation dans
les plans existants parce que souvent
ces marchés ont besoin d'avoir un accès
à l' International et je veux ici faire
le lien avec ce que je disais sur le le
numérique l'un des plans
particulièrement important c'est celui
de l'usine du futur j'ai eu l'occasion
dès la semaine dernière de passer en
revue les actions qui étaient prises
pourquoi pouroi parce que c'est celui
qui va regarder de manière très concrète
avec une déclinaison régionale
l'alliance de l'industrie classique du
numérique et des service et c'est à
travers les innovations mais aussi les
initiatives que nous pouvons prendre sur
les usines du futur dans les territoires
que nous pouvons essayer de rattraper la
bataille perdue dans la robotisation de
notre économie par rapport à nos grands
voisins en particulier aux Allemands le
deuxème niveau d'action c'est l'échelle
nationale et la là-dessus je veux sur le
plan macroéconomique juste donner
quelques points de de clarification qui
seront la la philosophie de mon de mon
action alors ça pourrait se résumer dans
une forme d'oxyore c'est de la stabilité
et le mouvement ce que je veux dire par
là c'est que sur le plan
macro-économique nous avons besoin
d'abord de stabilité sur le plan de la
fiscalité et des grandes décisions
fiscales et sociales nous avons pris
beaucoup de décisions pour y revenir
dans le débat beaucoup de choses ont été
annoncées le PCT de responsabilité et de
solidarité est une décision importante
qui a été annoncée dès le 14 janvier par
le Président de la République décliné
par le Premier ministre en avril dernier
je crois que la priorité aujourd'hui
c'est pour ce qui est du cice du PACT de
responsabilité et de solidarité d'en
assurer la stabilité dans les décisions
qui sont prises et l'exécution parce que
c'est c'est à cette condition que ce
plan trouvera son efficacité et que nous
pourrons redéclencher des comportements
d'investissement dans les entreprises et
de consommation chez les ménages ce plan
ces 40 milliards d'allègement de charges
et de fiscalité alors je sais bien ça
vient dans un paysage que de manière
extrêmement bipartisane nous avons
dégradé par la fiscalité mais néanmoins
cet engagement triénal il est important
parce que pour la première fois on
s'engage dans des contraintes de
finances publiques que nous connaissons
tous à allégé de 40 milliards sur 3 ans
je pense que il faut que collectivement
nous donnions à nos acteurs économiques
le signale que jusqu'au dernier centime
nous ferons ce plan ça suppose un esprit
de responsabilité des partenaires
sociaux d'une part et des organisations
patronales aussi d'autre part en
particulier en alimentant un dialogue
par branche qui me paraît être
extrêmement important parce qu'il est
l'incarnation de cette démocratie
sociale dans laquelle nous croyons qui
est à mes yeux un facteur de
compétitivité important d'ors et déjà
nous avons les premiers résultats
macro-économiques de cet engagement pour
la compétitivité la restauration des
marges de nos entreprise j'en veux pour
preuve les chiffres sortis le mois
dernier qui montrent que la France pour
la première fois depuis plusieurs années
a retrouver un coût horaire moyen
légèrement inférieur à celui de
l'Allemagne ce qui est important ce qui
s'explique d'une part par les premiers
effets du cice d'autre part par la
dynamique salariale qui est fortement
repartie en Allemagne mais il nous faut
reconverger progressivement pour
rattraper notre divergence passée je
crois qu'il faut aller au bout donc et
avoir de la stabilité en même temps il
faut accélérer les
réformes pour là aussi crédibiliser
notre volonté d'avoir une économie plus
compétitive et pour ouvrir cette
économie alors je veux ici manière
rapide parce que je suis déjà trop long
monsieur le Président essayer de dire
quel est la philosophie qui va
accompagner ce projet de loi pour la
croissance et l'activité que je
proposerai au Conseil des ministres le
10 décembre prochain et qui au premier
semestre de l'année prochaine sera
soumis donc à l'Assemblée au
Sénat ce projet de loi il avait été
initié par mon prédécesseur dans
l'esprit que vous rappeliez
ma volonté première la philosophie de ce
cette démarche ça n'est pas de
stigmatiser telle ou telle profession
faisz référence aux professions
réglementées ça n'est pas de considérer
qu'on va rattraper du pouvoir d'achat ou
de l'activité en allant je trouver une
victime expiatoire dans le reste de
notre économie c'est simplement quand on
considère l'économie française de
regarder de manière lucide que nous
sommes dans un monde qui bouge de plus
en plus vite que des P entiers de notre
économie se sont adaptés à cette
mondialisation parfois même nous l'avons
subi parce que nous n'avons pas su
l'accompagner et que pour réussir pour
que la France réussisse dans la
mondialisation celle qu'on veut celle
qu'on aura choisi et dans une Europe où
on réussira la notre devoir collectif
c'est de la préparer à celle-ci non pas
d'appliquer ce que j'entends parfois des
réforme que Bruxelles nous dicterait de
faire pour nous-mêmes à rigur ça
m'importe peu mais c'est pas parce qu'un
traitement
est indiqué par Bruxelles s il est bon
qu'on ne devrait pas se l'appliquer mais
c'est en regardant de manière très
pragmatique notre économie quels sont
les endroits où nous devons débloquer
les choses où nous devons ouvrir
davantage pourquoi pour parfois faire
baisser les prix pour surtout recréer de
l'activité où c'est possible et au-delà
de ça pour recréer des
opportunités pour les Françaises et les
Français c'est-à-dire
redonner davantage d'égalité de Chan
économique
les professions réglementées il s'agit
pas de stigmatiser qui que ce soit mais
pour n'en citer qu'une qui fait l'objet
de beaucoup de débats les notaires
honnêtement le notariat français
fonctionne bien il s'agit pas d'en
remettre en cause les fondamentaux ça
n'aurait rien à voir avec l'économie
pourquoi j'ai décidé dès le début que
l'acte authentique et son exclusivité
devait rester au notaire on va pas
sortir du droit canon en même temps
quand on regarde la partie économique de
ce qui'est le notariat français il y a
moins de nota en France aujourd'hui
qu'en 1980 600 offices de moins il y a
plus de 10 millions de francais de plus
et les transactions immobilières ont
augmenté de 250 % pendant cette période
est-ce que c'est sain quand on regarde
la population des
notaires les offices Notari sont tenus
par des notaires associés ils sont à
plus de 80 % des hommes de plus de 45
ans avec des revenus en moyenne je des
chiffres de l'Inspection des finances de
17000 € et quand on regarde les notaires
salariés qui en moyenne sont payés 4000
€ qui ont les mêmes diplômes les mêmes
stages ce sont là essentiellement des
femmes de moins de 45 ans c'est la
traduction qu'il y a quelque chose de
grippé dans ce secteur économique prenez
à côté les avocats qui n'est plus une
profession réglementé c'est la moyenne
d'âge doit être de 45 50 ans et c'est à
53 %
féminin c'est une preuve je ne parle pas
là de pouvoir d'achat dans la réforme
que nous proposons il y a des leviers
pour baisser les les tarifs des notaires
je veux simplement de manière
emblématique citer cet exemple pour
illustrer à quel point cela montre qu'il
y a un problème d'accès à une profession
et donc on peut tout à fait préserver
l'ADN du notariat français notre fierté
la sécurité juridique le maillage
territorial qui est fondamental mais en
même temps moderniser les règles
d'installation et d'accès à une
profession pour que celles et ceux qui
veulent entreprendre puissent le faire
dans un esprit méritocratique et ouvert
et je crois que les notaires ils sont
prêts puisque c'est une façon aussi de
les aider à affronter le monde de demain
et améliorer les services donc l'esprit
de cette loi pour les professions
réglementées c'est celui-là faciliter
les conditions d'accès les moderniser
aider à l'innovation de ces professions
qu'on appelle réglementé que parfois on
appelle libéral dans un paradoxe
toujours amusant mais en les rendant
précisément plus innovantes en mettant
plus de concurrence là où c'est sain on
a des tarifs est-ce que ces tarif se
justifie partout faut parfois que ce
soit des plafonds si certains sont prêts
à faire des actes un peu moins chers il
faut leur laisser la possibilité de le
faire je veux pas être trop long sur ce
sujet ouverture dans d'autres secteurs
comme les transports avec les les
autocar politique là aussi d'ouverture
du capital de nos entreprises avec une
réforme que je veux ambitieuse sur à la
fois l'épargne salarial et
l'actionnariat salarié pour que on
puisse retrouver un autre collectif dans
les entreprises françaises je crois
qu'on faut regarder les choses comme
elles sont nous avons abîmé l'éparne
salarial et il est important de
commencer à restaurer cet outil de
l'ouvrir aussi aux plus petites
entreprises parce que c'est un un point
important de compétitivité parce que ça
crée une autre collectivité humaine et
quand un chef d'entreprise un grand chef
d'entreprise du Nord de la France avait
coutume de dire lorsque mes salariés
sont aussi mes actionnaires je leur
parle différemment c'est c'est ça
l'actionnariat salarié lespines salarial
pardon et l'actionnariat salarié c'est
un vecteur important pour mobiliser
davantage les jeunes
et rémunérer de manière juste celles et
ceux qui prennent un un risque qui est
celui de l'entrepreneuriat et je crois
que là notre dispositif aujourd'hui
récompense insuffisamment celles et ceux
qui prennent un risque important qui
décident de ne pas être que des salariés
et qui aujourd'hui ne sont pas
suffisamment récompensés et c'est
important pour là aussi l'attractivité
et la compétitivité de notre économie et
de nos territoire enfin il y a un volet
relatif au travail dans ce ce projet de
loi parce que là aussi l'idée c'est
d'ouvrir le les choses de décloisonner
avec une réforme
sur le travail du dimanche qui s'appuie
sur les travaux de Monsieur bailli et de
la concertation qu'il avait mené une
simplification du dispositif plus de
l'attitude donné au maire dans les
ouvertures dominicales une règle de
compensation qui sera dans la loi ce qui
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui puisqu'il y
a des zones en particulier zones
touristiques où la compensation n'est
pas systématique et enfin pour les zones
d'intérêt touristique international et
des zones très attractifes sur le plan
économique et quelques grandes gares du
euh de notre économie la possibilité de
prendre par arrêté cette décision
d'ouvrir parce que
parfois la complexité de certains débats
locaux et l'intérêt supérieur que
justifie l'ouverture du dimanche dans
ces zones et et en soirée euh nous a
semblé justifier qu'on puisse reprendre
la main dans un esprit de concertation
avec les collectivités locales mais pour
pouvoir dans certains endroits très
symboliques où on sait que ouvrir le
dimanche en soirée créer de l'activité
de manière évidente et n'est pas un
déport d'activité pouvoir le faire
enfin nous proposons une réforme de des
prudommes j'oublie quelques autres P de
cette loi par esprit de de synthèse
parce que je veux qu'on ait de la place
pour le débat réforme des prudomes qui
avec François repsamen et Christian
tobira nous paraissait essentiel
Christian tobira en avait esquissé les
grandes lignes dans son projet de
justice du 21e siècle mais c'est aussi
une réforme économique parce que la
réalité aujourd'hui de notre justice
prudomale c'est 27 mois en moyenne de
délai c'est une conciliation qui était
la justification première de cette
organisation qui est de 6 % un tau de
réformation extrêmement important des
jugements et à Paris 4 ans pour le coup
de délai donc c'est une justice qui est
incertaine pour les salariés les plus
fragiles comme pour les petits patrons
et qui est longue nous pouvons la
réformer en respectant l'esprit originel
de ce qu'est la justice prudomale
c'est-à-dire en préservant le
paritarisme mais en accélérant les
délais en donnant de la visibilité par
une forme de barê sur les les peines qui
sont risqué et en facilitant la
procédure de de conciliation voilà je ne
veux pas être trop long sur ce sur ce
projet de loi mais je veux vous dire ici
que moi j'attends beaucoup du débat
parlementaire aussi bien à l'Assemblée
nationale qu'ici je veux que on puisse
le commencer au plus tôt parce que c'est
un texte qu'il faut enrichir
mais on peut voir ce texte de deux
façons la première comme une forme de
prise de risque politique maximale pour
le plaisir de le faire ou par posture ça
n'est pas ma philosophie la seconde elle
consisterait à dire que oui on s'attaque
à beaucoup de difficulté politique ou
sociétal oui on s'attaque à beaucoup de
corporatisme mais som toutes c'est aussi
ce dont notre pays souffre som toutes
aujourd'hui ce dont notre pays a besoin
ce dont notre économie a besoin c'est de
retrouver une forme d'espoir une forme
de perspective qui ne se réduisent pas à
des débats fiscaux ou sociaux que plus
personne ne comprend c'est qu'on redonne
la possibilité aux françaises et aux
Français qui veulent faire davantage qui
veulent prendre des initiatives de
pouvoir les prendre et que on ne regarde
pas toujours notre économie ou notre
société à l'ône des intérêts constitués
parce que ces intérêts constitués ils
sont importants pour notre économie pour
notre société notre vie politique mais
ils ne peuvent pas mobiliser l'ensemble
de nos forces et donc il faut redonner
des opportunités en particulier aux plus
jeunes en particulier à celles et ceux
qui sont condamnés au marge de de la
société du travail et qui ont énormément
d'envie d'initiative et de volonté enfin
je veux finir là-dessus c'est
l'Europe parce que le sens de tout ce
qu'on fait c'est je le disais tout à
l'heure de faire réussir l'économie
française dans la
mondialisation notre devoir c'est donc
de réformer l'économie française trop
longtemps et là aussi de manière
bipartisane notre notre attitude
classique avait été de dire on a un
problème on va remettre de l'argent
public parce que c'est plus simple c'est
plus traçable c'est plus évident et les
réformes que nous demande Bruxelles on
va négocier mais on va vous protéger de
ces
réformes notre volonté c'est de faire
l'inverse c'est difficile de réduire les
dépenses publiques on le sait bien on le
voit tous les jours c'est impopulaire
quand bien même on peut partager notre
la même volonté sur les principes la
mise en œuvre est toujours difficile
quelle que soit la zone que l'on touche
et les réformes que nous allons conduire
que j'espère conduire avec vous elles
seront difficiles mais elles sont
nécessaires et nous les faisons pour
pour nous-mêmes pour le bien de cette
économie mais parce que nous serons plus
forts parce que nous aurons fait ces
réformes pour nous-mêmes nous restaurons
aussi notre crédibilité vis-à-vis des
acteurs économiques de nos entreprises
qui n'attendent que ça et de nos
partenaires européens je peux vous dire
pour les voir régulièrement que nos
partenaires allemands nos partenaires
britanniques nos partenaires italiens
n'attendent qu'une chose c'est que nous
prenions nos responsabilités c'est que
nous modernisions le pays pour lui-même
et c'est à cette condition que nous
pourrons aussi être plus exigeant à
l'égard de l'Europe et en particulier à
l'égard du plan d'investissement qu'a
proposé le président Junker si nous
faisons de vraies réformes pour le pays
si nous prenons nos risqu dans notre
intérêt et dans celui de nos enfants
alors nous sommes en droit d'être
particulièrement exigeant à l'égard de
nos partenaires européens et de l'Europe
parce que ce dont nous avons besoin
aujourd'hui c'est d'un plan
d'investissement européen qui puisse
faire ce que ce qui n'aurait pas de sens
de faire au niveau national c'est-à-dire
un vrai plan d'investissement les 300
milliards du président Junker il faut
que que ce soit du vrai argent de
l'argent en plus pour qu'un choc
macroéconomique au niveau de la zone
euro puisse advevenir c'est ça dont nous
avons besoin pour accompagner notre
politique qui est plus une politique
d'offre d'une vraie politique de demande
au niveau de la zone euro et de l'Union
européenne ce plan de 300 milliards en 3
ans c'est 10 milliards d'euros pour
l'économie française par an donc je le
dis ici nous devons collectivement être
exigeant avec l'Europe sur ce volet
investissement nous ne pourrons l'être
que si nous montrons que nous sommes
exigeants avec nous-mêmes et que nous
reformons l'économie voilà là la ligne
d'ensemble la philosophie que je voulais
pour cette première discussion exposer
auprès de vous monsieur le Président
j'ai j'ai j'en ai conscience du coup
très peu parlé du budget de mon
ministère mais je propose de y répondre
dans les questions si elle venait sur ce
sujet mais je trouvais plus important
d'essayer de redonner une cohérence
merci Monsieur Je diraai pas que ce que
vous avez à dire budget n'a pas
d'importance mais c'est effectivement
secondaire par rapport à la politique
que vous avez tracé c'est la première
fois que vous vous êtes devant la
commission donc nous apprécions
évidemment d' vous avoir entendu sur ce
point euh simplement avant de donner la
parole en l'espace de 30 secondes quel
est le calendrier prévisionnel du
passage devant le Sénat du projet de loi
qui porte déjà votre nom écoutez c'est
un projet de loi qui sera donc POS en
conseil des ministres le 10 le 10
décembre qui je crois passera les
calendriers sont encore fluctuants et et
et là-dessus je ne peux vous donner que
ce que j'ai comme information stable on
me dit fin du mois de janvier à
l'Assemblée h ce qui suppose compte tenu
de la charge de votre propre calendrier
que je passerai au Sénat en mars c'est
ça en mars d'accord bien merci c'est
pour organiser nos travaux puisque nous
avons également la transition
énergétique qui va nous occuper un un
certain temps alors je d'abord la parole
à Alain Châtillon au tit de
l'UMP messieurs les ministres et Madame
surtout au garonaise elle aussi qui se
succède avec après un auogaronais alors
monsieur le ministre d'abord sur les
professions réglementées je ne suis pas
notaire donc je vous en parle très
librement je considère que là il faut
faire très
attention les notaires aujourd'hui
euh apportent notamment en rural et en
pérri urbain des conseils le plus
souvent
gratuit ce n'est pas un acte chaque fois
qu'il reçoivent quelqu'un c'est
différent dans d'autres professions là
c'est pas le cas le deuxème point vous
avez parlé d'augmentation de population
importante oui augmentation de
population importante essentiellement en
cour parisienne et sur Paris et dans les
très grandes
villes attention ne pas affaiblir les
quelques études qui restent en rural et
sur ce plan-là je vous demande de
vraiment réfléchir à ce point quand vous
allez passer un acte sur un noter à
Paris il y a 30 40 60 quelquefois une
centaine de clair quand vous allez chez
un notaire de province il a deux voire
trois salariés donc ne créez pas quelque
chose qui va créer la diversit ification
la désertification de nos territoires le
deuxième point s'il y a taxation c'est
la taxation au montant de l'acte mais
pas à l'acte petit donc faites la
différence entre ceux qui font des
grosses opérations des signatures
d'actes très importants en peu de temps
et ceux qui en rural notamment dans le
rural profond de nos territoires voi de
3 qu ou C clients 10 fois pour passer de
tout petits actes et enfin la
valorisation du fond de commerce
attention à laaspoliation ce sont des
gens qui ont passé une vie entière pour
valoriser un fond de commerce le plus
souvent familial donc j'attire votre
attention sur ces trois points
importants je suis intervenu avec des
collègues socialistes récemment à
Toulouse et notamment avec mon collègue
Borgel devant l'assemblée des notaires
il a convenu d'un certain nombre de
point je souhaiterais que vous soyez
très vigilant là-dessus euh vous savez
quel est l'exode dans nos territoir
ruraux et vous savez la difficulté que
nous avons à maintenir des activités ça
c'est le premier point deème point c'est
sur le plan des
entreprises j'ai créé et développé un
pôle qui c'est devenu important puisque
en pôle agro midi pyrené et akiten qui
est devenu aujourd'hui l'un des deux
premiers pôles
français lorsque je vois qu'aujourd'hui
l'État va réduire de 30 % l'aide à ce
pôle alors il y a deux cas de figure on
lui donne des compétences élargi
notamment de conseil ou de formation
pourquoi pas mais réduire de 30 %
c'est-à-dire ramener à 80000 € pour un
pôle qui représente 200000 salariés je
trouve que c'est pas cher payer pour des
gens qui le font gratuitement car tout
nous avons un pôle avec SEP personnes
SEP salariés pour couvrir deux régions
ça touche 200000 salariés 350
entreprises et qui effectivement jouent
un rôle r majeur dans l'accompagnement
et dans cet accompagnement je vous
invite à regarder également l'action de
la cofas qui petit à petit se retire et
n'accompagne que très rarement les
sociétés sur des pays dit dangereux je
pense même à l'Espagne aujourd'hui donc
regardons ce problème là et puis enfin
l'accompagnement uif France et tous les
toutes les activités qui tournent autour
est-ce qu'on ne peut pas depuis et là je
ne vous en fais pas le GF sen faux ce
n'est qu'un constat mais deu depuis 7 8
ans on n'arrive pas à fédérer et
accompagner regardons ce qu'on fait les
japonais avec le MITI regardons ce que
font les Allemands regardons ce que font
les les Italiens et regardons la
capacité de nos deux pays voisins Italie
et Allemagne sur la capacité à créer des
ETI comment peut-on créer des ETI dans
ce pays alors qu'aujourd'hui nos ETI il
y en a trois fois moins qu'en Allemagne
et deux fois moins qu'en Italie et que
de sur croix la marge opérationnelle de
ces ETI françaises est deux fois plus
plus petite que celle de nos
voisins et àite on s'étonne d'avoir 60
et quelques milliards de déficit la
balance commercial commençons
accompagner ces entreprisesl commençons
à fédérer des PME et c'est l'un des
rôles des pôles de d'excellence ou des
pôles de compétitivité que
d'effectivement faire en sorte de
regrouper un certain nombre de
partenaires qui sont capables de créer
demain un ETI et quel système
d'accompagnement vous avez parlé de la
BPI bon il y a un certain nombre de
groupes financiers existant depuis bien
des années dans certaines régions je
pense à l'IRDI en méieipyrénée je pense
à si parx dans ou à Nord entreprendre
donc ces sociétés ont la capacité
d'accompagner essayons de mobiliser des
financiers trouvons des financements
extérieurs mais essayons vraiment car ce
sont les ETI qui vont véritablement
apporter de la valeur ajoutée quand on
voit qu'on continue à perdre 70000
emplois industriels depuis 1980 on est
passé de
5300000 emploi à moins de 2 millions et
demi soyons vigilants et accompagnons
nos
entreprises bien merci mercies chers
collègues vous l'avez constaté le chrono
a démarré avec beaucoup de retard ce qui
fait que on a l'impression que notre
collègue a dépassé le temps de parole
qui lui était imparti celui qui va lui
succéder devant le micro c'est Martial
Bourquin monsieur le ministre merci de
votre présentation et et surtout j'ai
ressenti dans votre propos la la volonté
de mettre l'entreprise et la création de
valeur au cœur de des des préoccupation
gouvernemental la question de
l'industrie est une question essentielle
et nous devons sur ces questions-l
redevenir une grande nation industrielle
et pour cela bien sûr faut retrouver des
marches dans les entreprises mais il
faut aussi retrouver cette culture
industrielle que nous avons perdu et
c'est avec c'est en choisiss des
créneaux nouveaux que nous arriverons à
retrouver ces lettes de noblesse dans
l'industrie et on sent qu'il y a une
volonté de vous avez cité votre
prédécesseur mais vous aussi vous gardez
cette volonté de redevenir une une
société productive moi je souhaiterais
attirer votre attention sur les
conditions dans lesquelles vont être
transposé dans enendroit interne les
deux directive relativ au marchés
publics qui ont été adoptés cette année
au niveau de la Communauté
européenne la la commande publique
représente environ 100 milliards d'euros
et le point qui me qui mérite une
attention particulière concerne le
recours à la sous-traitance dans les
marchés
publics la directive du 26 février 2014
donne une
large dire une certaine marge de
manœuvre assez large aux États-membres
sur ce point
elle indique que le respect par les
sous-traitants des obligation dans les
domaines du droit environnemental social
et du travail doivent être assurer ça
c'est très important et ça ça représente
des mesures appropriées prises par les
autorités nationales il dispose aussi
qu'il est nécessaire d'assurer une
certaine transparence dans la chaîne de
la sous-traitance je vais vous donner un
exemple très particulier il un grand
chantier de 300 millions qui se fait
dans ma région et aujourd'hui
ce qui s'est passé dans l'industrie au
niveau de de ce qu'on a appelé les
délocalisations risque de se faire aussi
dans le bâtiments les travaux publics
parce que des sociétés se mettent en
place avec des appels d'offre qui sont
maintenant tous européens et sur ces
appels d'offre il y a comment une grande
partie de salariés détachés et j'ai
demandé au préfet qu'il y ait des
contrôles un contrôle qui a été opéré
encore hier soir a exclu une société du
marché parce qu'elle avait des
difficultés AC son Fiss à hauteur de 40
millions d'euros mais le choir l du
contrôle c'est pas moins de 12
nationalité qui était présente sous le
chantier et à côté de cela nos
PME nos TPE sont en grave difficulté et
là voyez-vous je pense que il y a eu
deux choses qui se sont passées qui sont
très importantes la première c'est que
on a plus l'obligation maintenant pour
une PME lorsquelle postule sur un marché
d'avoir en chiffre d'affaire le double
du marché et deuxième chose on a
l'alotissement qui a été aussi un
progrès mais là je pense que dans la
transposition qui va s'opérer et dans
les marges de manœuvre qui vous sont
donné est-ce que cette transparence dans
la chaîne de la
sous-traitance doit pas être utilisé
avec l'empreinte
carbone pour faire en sorte que nous
ayons cette politique de Pacte PME qui
se m en place pour faire en sorte
vraiment que les marchés publics bien
sûr on va pas se retrouver dans une
situation où on capte tout mais là
aujourd'hui dans une grande partie un
grand donneur d'or par exemple à jouer
le jeu à distribuer à l'ensemble de nos
PME je vais pas les citer
ici le gros œuvres dans les finitions ça
a été catastrophique et là je crois
qu'il faut faire attention il y a des
mesures à prendre des contrôles à opérer
et pas seulement des contrôles
instantané pour savoir si ces personnes
ont des papiers en règle mais pour
connaître aussi pourquoi une société
arrive à faire un dumping fiscal et
social et honté et aller chercher des
marchés que nos sociétés ne pourraient
pas euh comment remplir parce que on est
en dessous du coup de revien euh ça me
semble une question euh très importante
parce que comment on on sent aujourd'hui
nos nos comment nos nos entrepreneurs du
bâtiment et nos salariés du bâtiment
très inquiets sur une situation qui
semble leur échapper dernière
chose Monsieur le Ministre sur les
questions des des délais de paiement euh
on sent l'observatoire de Monsieur
Lorenzi va donner en décembre son son
verdict il semble que les délis de
paiement s'aggravent encore entre les
grands donneurs d'ordre et les les
sous-traitants et la question que posait
mon collègue Chatillon qui est une
question très pertinente sur les ETI il
semble bien qu'une des raisons pourquoi
nous n'avons pas plus deti ce sont les
rapports entre les grands donneurs d'ord
et les sous-traitants parce que le mle
stand à l'allemande ça ne se fait pas
chez nous chez nous la la culture c'est
de TDE le sous-traitant et sur ces
questionslà des délais de paiement dans
la loi consommation nous avions mis en
place toute une série de
mesures et est-ce que les décrets
d'application vont paraître sur ces
mesures les informations que j'avais
c'est qu'il paraîtrai en décembre mais
j'ai l'impression que sur ces délis de
paiement il y a un travail à faire ça
participe à la désindustrialisation
monsieur le ministre ça participe à la
désindustrialisation bien merci Martial
Bourquin
ladislasadovski merci monsieur le
président oui une seule question
monsieur le
ministre jeis vous avouer j'ai je buvais
du petit lait en vous écoutant notamment
lorsque vous nous avez fait la petite
synthèse de votre projet de loi pour la
croissance et et vous serez
vraisemblablement surpris à mon avis
lorsque le débat va venir au Parlement
vous risquez d'avoir plus de soutien
dans nos rangs que dans vos propres
rangs vous avez dit on s'attaque à des
corporatismes c'est pas des
corporatismes que vous vous êtes attaqué
ça va être à votre propre majorité je
pense que vous aurez des problèmes ma
question pourte sur un volet qui est je
pense un des plus intéressant ce n'est
pas l'ouverture le dimanche c'est ce que
vous avez dit concernant l'ouverture du
capital et sur l'ouverture du capital
j'espère que vous ferez preuve de
beaucoup d'initiativ et que vous irez
très loin vous avez tout à fait raison
de dire que cette ouverture du capital
doit profiter à ceux qui prennent des
risque c'est-à-dire aux actionnaires et
doit absolument profiter en même temps
aux salariés c'est la seule manière
de de réinjecter et de redynamiser et
d'aider au développement de beaucoup
d'entreprises mais pas les grandes
toutes les grandes les moyennes les
petites les PME vous avez cité voir des
petites entreprises artisanales et
j'espère bien que vous irez loin
j'espère que vous irez loin et sur cette
ce domaine là et ce volet là nous vous
soutiendrons et j'aurais été ravi
d'avoir quelques précisions si vous êtes
déjà prêt à nous en donner bien merci
merci Michel
swarnek micro mon chers collègues est-ce
que ça fonctionne là merci quelques
questions d'abord par rapport au cice
sur les 40 milliards donc est-ce qu'on
pourrait avoir une évaluation annuelle
pu s'étale sur 3 ans je nous sommes
assez critiques sur cette question parce
qu'il n'y a pas d'engagement ferme il y
a pas de règles de critère d'attribution
euh qui sont porteurs de de réussite
pour notre part c'est ce que nous voyons
je vous ai entendu dire le coout horaire
baisse donc ce sont les premiers
résultats vous avez dit ensuite faire
baisser les prix c'est un objectif
est-ce que c'est en tirant tout vers le
bas qu'on va pouvoir relancer notre
industrie donc c'est une question que je
me pose est-ce qu'il faut est-ce que
dans la compétition internationale
mondiale mondialisation il s'agit de
tout tirer vers le bas est-ce que c'est
ça l'avenir par ailleurs je voulais dire
en début mais j'ai oublié par par
rapport au collègue Châtillon j'étais
d'accord avec son analyse sur les
professions réglementées donc j'ai reçu
beaucoup de notaires et et d'huissers et
de pharmaciens donc je pense qu' qu'il
joue un rôle fondamental pour notre
tissu local et qui rend un service
public information gratuite tout ceci me
paraît tout à fait vrai peut-être qu'il
y a des changements à apporter mais en
tout cas avec beaucoup de de
prudence sur la réforme des prudomes
donc je ne connais pas exactement la vie
des syndicats mais serait peut-être bon
qu'on tienne de la vie des syndicats qui
sont quand même concernés au premier
chef et l'autre question c'est par
rapport au retraite chapeau est-ce que
tout à l'heure jean-tirrol a parlé de
code d'éthique est-ce que la question
des retraites chapeau ça rendre dans
dans le code d'éthique est-ce qu'il faut
continuer à accepter les retraites
chapeau à ce niveau faut-il les
interdire faut-il les réduire faut-il
les taxés donc j'aimerais connaître
votre opinion sur ce sujet et pour
terminer sur la banque centrale EUR
européenne je me pose la question est-ce
que c'est est-ce que ce serait une bonne
chose si la Banque centrale européenne
prêtait aux États au même taux qu'aux
banques voilà je je me pose vraiment
cette question merci bien merci mon cher
collègue monsieur le ministre vous
invite si vous voulez bien à porter des
réponses à ces
questions alors par souci de cohérence
comme je donne toujours la parole à
chaque groupe euh Joël Labé qui
représente à lui seul le groupe écolo
n'avait pas levé le doigt mais donc
comme ça vous aurez des représentant de
tous les groupes Joël tu as la parole
euh oui monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre monsieur
le Président c'est parce que vous aviez
pris la très bonne habitude de donner la
parole à chat je m'étais je m'étais dit
que c'était plus la peine de la demander
mais je vais faire très rapide oui mais
j'oblige pas quelqu'un par modeste écolo
d'abord concernant le point de vue des
notaires sur l'expérience d'une
vingtaine d'années que de ma que j'ai eu
aussi donc je les ai reçus les notaires
mais j'ai ma propre expérience il y a
certes nécessité de de de de réformer
mais c'est véritablement comme le
disaient mes deux collègues c'est un
service de proximité on parlait hier des
milieux ruraux et hyper ruraux c'est un
véritable service de proximité pour la
population alors pour les élus locaux
également c'était pratiquement chaque
semaine où j'avais à faire au notaire y
compris pour des rendez-vous où il se
déplaçait jamais j'ai pensé lui demander
combien je lui devais et jamais il a il
a il a eu le le réflexe de me le dire ce
côté-là est drôlement important je crois
que entre les avocats parisiens les gros
cabinets d'avocats de grande ville et
les les petits offices notarios de de
campagne il y a une nuance à à
véritablement prendre en compte euh
monsieur le ministre par rapport à à la
à la à la question de la transition
euh notamment transition énergétique
transition dans les transports également
il y a de de nouvelles activités de
nouveaux métiers une nouvelle économie
j'aimerais que vous puissiez nous en
dire un un peu plus là-dessus et
toujours dans le même domaine
l'adaptation des métiers du bâtiment au
nouveau modes de construction et de
rénovation voilà pour les quelques
points que je souhaitais soulever
merci bien monsieur le minist si vous
voulez prendre la
parole merci beaucoup pour ces question
alors je vais peut-être commencer par le
notariat puisque c'est un sujet
bipartisan et
important je partage votre sensibilité à
tous trois qui qui en avait parlé c'est
aujourd'hui le notariat français fait
partie des éléments de sécurité
juridique l'acte authentique est
important il fait partie de ce qu'on
appelle le maillage territorial de
l'équilibre des territoires et il rend
un vrai service public donc la volonté
notre volonté n'est pas de casser le
notariat français de ne pas prendre en
compte ces mesures jeis simplement
essayer de vous dire comment ça marche
marche aujourd'hui de manière simple et
comment on propose que ça marche demain
aujourd'hui pour créer un office
ministériel il faut que vous soyez
présenté par un notaire qui détient un
office ce qui n'est pas totalement
conforme je crois à l'idée que nous
pouvons
partager honnêtement de ni de
l'entrepreneuriat ni de la méritocratie
républicaine parce que ça veut dire que
si vous ne trouvez pas un
notaire qui par le droit de présentation
vous ctes entreprise et généralement si
vous n'êtes pas quelqu'un qu' l'aime
bien qu' a pris par connaître ou son
neveu ou son fils vous pouvez avoir le
même diplôme le même stage le même test
d' la même honorabilité reconnu par le
Garde des sauts et ne pas avoir de
perspective de tenir un office
notarial vous pouvez en créer un nouveau
et c'est soumis à une commission la clon
qui a une politique il faut bien le dire
très maltusienne le résultat des courses
c'est ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure à l'heure il y a 600 offices
notaria de moins qu'en
1980 donc ces éléments peuvent nous
conduire à penser que le système est un
peu conservateur c'est la réalité où
sont aujourd'hui les déserts Notari ils
ne sont pas en monde rural les déserts
Notari quand prends juste un critère de
rapport de nombre d'office à la
population et à la richesse ils sont en
scè saintis ou plutôt en banlieu de de
métropole où est la concentration de la
richesse notariale vous avez raison elle
est beaucoup plus dans les endroit où
l'immobilier a flambé et où on a pu
avoir précisément plus de rent je moi je
je ne veux stigmatiser personne je dis
simplement que nous avons surréglementé
pour de bonnes raisons une profession
donc il faut garder la bonne
réglementation mais peut-être lever
celle qui est inutile et donc ce qu'on
propose de faire c'est que lorsqu'un
notaire aura passé le diplôme lorsque ce
notaire aura passé son stage qu'il aura
été reconnu comme pouvant être notaire à
plein par la garde des sauts donc
l'honorabilité donc il aura passé toutes
les fourches codines juridiques qui vous
garantissent la qualité de sa
prestation il sera partout où c'est
possible en situation de créer un
office alors le risque me direz-vous
c'est de déséquilibrer des territoires
d'enlever des parts de marché à ceux qui
sont là et bien nous av proposé de
supprimer pour les différentes
professions existantes les sept
commissions existantes pour avoir un
collège unique de professionnels qui
serait attaché à l'Autorité de la
concurrence et qui regarderait selon des
critères très objectifs de population de
richesse sur les territoires et qui
dirait voilà le niveau satisfaisant de
notaire et donc quand il y en a assez on
on autorise pas à créer sur ce
territoire ce qui permettrait d'orienter
la création d'office nouveaux vers les
territoires où il en manque et donc
quand vous avez suffisamment d'offic
notaria point n'est besoin d'en créer et
donc c'est un peu inversé la logique qui
consiste qui consiste aujourd'hui à dire
c'est interdit partout sauf autorisation
exclusive une commission malthusienne et
parce que ça a été géré de manière un
peu conservatrice à une logique qui
consiste à dire lorsque vous avez rempli
tous vos tests juridiques et que la
qualité est garantie c'est autorisé sauf
si vous déstabilisez un écosystème
existant je crois que ça répond à vos
préoccupations en mettant un peu plus en
reconnaissant que il y a aussi somme
toute dans le notariat français une
dynamique économique une logique
économique que nous voyons tous enfin
sur les tarifs
il y a aujourd'hui une péréquation de
fait dans les tarifs parce qu'en effet
les petits actes sont plutôt
soustarifés en dessous du cous réel et
l'équilibre se fait par les grands actes
les plus gros mais cette péréquation
elle a un sens macroéconomique enfin les
offices qui font beaucoup de petits
actes font rarement des très gros actes
et inversement nous connaissons tous et
toutes des offices notariaux qui font
surtout des gros actes et peu de petits
actes à
perte et donc il faudrait pas que cette
péréquation de fait dont il faut garder
la logique soit le prétexte pour ne rien
regarder des tarifs existants parce que
ces tarifs figurez-vous ils n'ont pas
bougé depuis
1978 ce qui somme toute est l'indicateur
là aussi de quelque chose qui peut être
réadapté au monde dans lequel nous
vivons donc ce que nous proposons c'est
de garder une logique de péréquation
c'est-à-dire que ce soit pas qu'on gagne
pas surtout pour baisser le prix des
plus gros actes et qu'on garde sur les
les actes les plus petits une logique
par rapport au coups réel mais que on
puisse avoir de manière régulière une
révision de ces tarifs à la lumière d'un
rapport indépendant qui sera fait par
l'Autorité de la concurrence rapport que
nous avons d'ailleurs demandé pour la
fin d'année et qui ustrera la réalité
des coûts réels de ces professions et
des tarifs qui sont aujourd'hui proposés
enfin il semblait important qu'on puisse
introduire une logique un peu différente
cohérente avec l'ouverture de ces
professions qui est que ces tarifs
pourra être un
plafond que vous garantissez partout sur
le territoire que vous ne pouvez pas
payer plus de X un acte mais dans
certains territoires pourquoi un notire
entreprenant plus innovant qui
s'organise mieux pourrait pas faire cet
acte pour un peu moins cher il est
responsable de manière pleine entière il
va pas s'amuser à faire de mauvais actes
ça je ne crois pas cette théorie par
contre il est évident que un jeune
notaire qui voudrait s'installer à Paris
puisque vous ctiezsieur sénateur tout à
l'heure cet exemple un jeune notaire qui
voudrait s'installer à Paris je peux
vous dire que pour gagner des parts de
marché il ferait sans doute beaucoup
d'actes moins chers que ses collègues
aujourd'hui installés la qualité n'en
serait pas moins bonne et simplement
vous créez une logique de concurrence
elle est normale elle est normale si
vous n'atteignez pas à si je puis dire
au cœur juridique du notariat donc voilà
la philosophie de ce cette réforme
elle n'est pas évidente pour tout le
monde je pense qu'elle est entendue en
tout cas très
honnêtement moi je ne me résou pas à
l'idée que dans le monde où on vit
expliquer chaque jour que les salariés
doivent s'adapter que les PME doivent se
faire à la mondialisation que la
compétitivité est une réalité et qu'à
côté on dit il faut vivre sous le régime
de ventose et la loi 1943 avec des
tarifs de 1978 soit extraordinairement
logique et intellectuellement
satisfaisant on peut préserver le cœur
de notre droit sa sécurité juridique et
moderniser tout cela pour le bien du
pays pour ce qui est des pôles de
compétitivité alors je je crois qu'il y
a eu euh monsieur sénateur affilé mais
je vais quand même avorter la réponse
pour tout le monde oui oui non obligé de
rentrer sur Toulouse ouis et et donc euh
parce que là-dessus on a eu le débat euh
sur le budget
assemblée je pense qu'il y a une
confusion parfois entre les chiffres il
y a sur les 71 pôles de compétitivité
les dotations de fonctionnement et les
et les dotations d'investissement sur le
fonctionnement
euh on est passé de 16 millions d'euros
pour ce qui est de mon ministère mais
qui ne représente pas l'intégralité des
dotations la dotation totale de l'État
c'est 22 millions d'euros parce que
certains sont portés par d'autres
ministères mais pour les donc la part
des autres est préservée pour notre
ministère on passe de 16 à 14 et non
11,5 comme initialement prévu parce
qu'en gestion on va rajouter 2 millions
et demi le reste de l'effort sera fait
par les régions c'est l'accord politique
qu'on a trouvé ce qui correspond donc le
passage de 16 à 14 moins de 5 % de
baisse qui est conforme à la baisse des
crédits qu'on fait sur le reste du
ministère et dans la plupart des des
ministères donc c'est cohérent et je
pense soutenable l'effort
d'investissement et lui préservé même
renforcé via le paia il passe lui
principalement par le fond Unique
Interministériel 110 millions en 2014 et
il sera stabilisé sur le triénal à 100
millions par an d'engagement et dans le
P 2 on a doté de 300 millions d'euros
les initiative sur les pôles de
compétitivité donc l'idée n'est pas du
tout un désengagement massif sur plan
financier et je je regrette à ce titre
et je veux m'en excuser qui pu avoir des
courriers émanant de mon ministère qui
ont
pu en anticipant des décisions qui
parfois étit plus dur que ce qu'on a
finalement décidé créer le trouble ou
l'incertitude en tout cas la confusion
donc voilà le la réalité des choses pour
ce qui est de la cofas alors je sais que
c'est un sujet de préoccupation il est
important pour nos
entreprises la cofas il y a deux choses
il y a ce qu'on appelle le compte état
la partie publique c'est 5 à 8 milliards
d'engagements chaque année et donc là
nous avons nous sommes très vigilants et
préservons pour ce qui est du compte
privé on ne le gère pas c'est principe
en lui d'ailleurs qui accompagne les
entreprises en Europe est totalement
privé et donc on aura une vigilance et
on va regarder l'action j'ai bien noté
le point qui était fait mais n'avons pas
de levier sur ce sujet là par contre sur
l'organisation de notre dispositif à
l'export je veux ici insister sur deux
choses BPI France a lancé à doté vousavz
voté un programme BPI export une part
qui est extrêmement important et d'autre
part nous avons
regroupé la fi donc l'agence pour les
investisseurs internationaux et ubi
France en une entité unique qui
justement doit être beaucoup plus
efficace et beaucoup plus simple pour
nos entreprises pour aller à
l'international après on sait bien que
la complexité elle se situe aussi
beaucoup dans la multiplicité des
acteurs que nous avons parfois sur les
territoires et donc là il faut créer
beaucoup de cohérence et c'est une
vigilance nous devons tous avoir
ensemble mais je crois qu'on a un
dispositif qui est en tout cas plus
compétitif et il faut là-dessus
continuer à être exigeant sur le point
des ETI qui est un point fondamental moi
je crois que pour que ça marche mieux
les ETI on a un sujet qui rejoint celui
qu'on évoqué d'un de rémunération de
ceux qui prennent des risques et de
bonnes incitations fiscales pour les
entrepreneurs parce que un entrepreneur
qui réussit il faut qu'il soit
récompensé fiscalement c'est les
aménagements que je proposerai en
matière de bon de souscription part de
créateur d'entreprise et d'action de
performance
ensuite le sujet des E en France c'est
un sujet de fond propre pour beaucoup on
a moins de capitalisme familial qu'en
Allemagne et c'est un capitalisme du
coup qui est en effet parfois plus
courttermiste qui se développe moins je
pense que toute la réflexion qui a été
lancée sur les seuils en particulier les
seuils sociaux qui é la négociation est
importante elle fait partie de ces
mesures qui permettent à nos entreprises
de lever un des plafonds de verre qui
existent l'accompagnement à l'export
l'ouverture à l'international de nos PME
leur permettra aussi de devenir des des
ETI le point des délais de paiement sur
lequel je vais revenir est un facteur
mais il faut là avoir une politique en
matière de fonds propres beaucoup plus
favorable pour nos PME je pense qu'on
fera dans les prochains mois des des
propositions concrètes c'est pas un
problème de financement en dette c'est
vraiment un problème de financement en
fond propre pour qu'on puisse continuer
à croître et à
réussir pour les sujets qui ont été
évoqués par Monsieur le Sénateur
Bourquin alors sur la la la culture
industrielle de notre pays vous l'avez
vous l'avez dit vous avez raison je veux
ici rinister sur un point je le disais
rapidement tout à l'heure nous avons
raté dans la fin des années 80 une
première bataille industrielle qui était
celle de la robotisation nous avons
aujourd'hui une bataille qui s'ouvre qui
est celle de ce que les Allemands
appellent industrie 4.0 qui est comment
inventer l'usine du futur l'industrie du
futur qui va permettre de la production
très décentralisée avec ses imprimantes
3D qui sont déjà une réalité avec une
autre organisation du tui productif et
où on va devoir marier la production
industrielle avec le numérique et ses
innovations puis que certaines parties
de la chaîne de production vont aller
beaucoup plus vite et s'organiser
différemment et les services attachés
parce qu'aujourd'hui ce qu'on vend ça
n'est plus simplement matériel c'est de
l'intelligence embarquée et ce sont des
services et donc je crois que si on se
pose la question de la culture
industrielle et notre réussite
industrielle il faut aussi se la poser
de manière différente ce qui est
peut-être une nouvelle opportunité pour
la France parce que il faut décloisonner
ce que nous avons toujours regardé en
silo l'industrie aujourd'hui n'est plus
la sœur ennemie des services c'est faux
les emplois que nous recréerons en
développant l'industrie ce ne sont pas
dans des emplois dans des usine qui
fument ce sont des emplois de service
attachés à des matériaux qu'on produit
en France et donc il faut être beaucoup
plus innovant beaucoup plus transversaux
mais ce qui veut dire aussi ne pas avoir
peur de cette nouvelle mondialisation
pas considérer que les Françaises et les
Français qui seraient abonnés à la
vieille industrie n'auraient pas de
place dans la nouvelle industrie c'est
faux ça veut dire avoir beaucoup
d'anticipation et réfléchir
collectivement
ça veut dire faire les investissements
au bons endroits pour développer ces
clusters de compétences ça veut dire
investir dans les formations pour
réussir sur ces sujets parce que
j'insiste il faut qu'on puisse former
les Françaises et les Français pour les
accompagner dans ce changement et et
cette évolution et ça veut dire ne pas
avoir peur du changement et je dirais
que culturellement on réussira ce ce
virage industriel si on n' pas peur du
changement si on explique aux Français
et aux Français que la nouvelle
robotisation ça n'est pas l'ennemi de
l'emploi je cite toujours un exemple
très simple il y a cinq fois plus de
robots dans les usines allemandes que
dans les usines
françaises l'industrie pèse plus en
Allemagne qu'en France et il y a un taux
de chômage qui est presque deux fois
inférieur donc si les robots tuaient des
emplois ça serait en tout cas ça se
serait vu donc il faut pas avoir peur de
cette de ce changement mais il faut
l'accompagner surtout il faut
l'anticiper sur les marchés publics vous
avez évoqué un point important donc il y
a deux directives qui ont effectivement
réformé les marchés publics en février
2014 je vais d'ici la fin de l'année
lancer une consultation sur l'ordonnance
de transposition qui qui sera prise sur
l'habilitation l'habilitation sera
incluse dans le projet de loi
d'habilitation au en cours de de de
discussion et cette transposition elle
doit être l'occasion d'une réforme en
profondeur qui aidera les entreprises en
particulier les PME parce que je
souscris totalement à vos préoccupations
vos préoccupations pour les PME ce sont
celles que nous portons et que nous
avons
porté d'abord dans la loi
ESS et dans toutes les mesures qui ont
été prises parce que les clauses
sociales les critères sociaux qui qui
sont qui figurent dans dans ces
dispositions sont de nature précisément
là aussi à protéger nos PME et à éviter
les pratiques que vous mentionnez et
nous avons aggravé également les
sanctions administratives en cas de
défaut de déclaration de de détachement
donc il y a des premières mesures qui
ont été prises mais il faut aller plus
loin d'autres mesures complémentaires
ont été prises j'ai simplifié en
particulier les règles de marché public
pour les PME en réduisant le nombre de
pièces demandées c'est bon pour les PME
françaises mais au-delà de ça il faut
être très vigilant sur le point vous
avez raison du détachement et de
l'organisation de la chaîne
précisément de de de production et de
fourniture de de ces marchés publics et
donc on doit simplifier massivement les
textes et aller plus loin que ce que
nous avons fait
rendre donc plus accessibles les
possibilités d'alotissement parce que
c'est bon pour pour les PME et renforcer
encore sans doute puisque les directives
nous ite à faire les clauses sociales et
environnementales alors cette réforme
elle s'inscrit dans la droite ligne de
de ce qui a été je disais engagé en
septembre dernier avec les mesures de
simplification et les approches
nouvelles comme le partenariat pour
l'innovation qui est quelque chose aussi
que nous avons mis en place pour les PME
en particulier pour les pour les marchés
publics mais donc dans le cadre de cette
concertation on on vous associera pour
que vos préoccupations puissent être
pleinement pris en compte pour ce qui
est des délais de paiement alors euh
aujourd'hui nous avons euh dans la loi
le délai de 60
jours c'est tout à fait vrai qu'il n'est
largement pas
respecté la transparence complète
m'oblige à dire qu'il est parfois pas
respecté
par des entités des administrations
publiques également et par des grandes
entreprises publiques donc l'enjeu c'est
d'abord d'assurer le respect de cette de
cette loi avec la volonté de donner et
vous évoquiez ces texes une nouvelle
dynamique dans trois dire tion d'abord
des contrôles accrus de la DGCCRF il y a
l'objectif de 2500 contrôles en 2014
j'en rendrai compte en temps voulu
ensuite la mise en œuvre dans la loi
conso qui donne un rôle de suivi
particulier au commissaire au comptes et
à cet égard le décret est en préparation
il sera pris avant la fin d'année et
l'amélioration euh justement du côté du
secteur public avec des mesures très
concrètes euh que je veux prendre d'ici
la fin de l'année mais qui sont des
mesures d'ailleurs de quasiment de
stigmatisation parfois de certains
acteurs qui ne respectent pas les règles
il y a cette norme anglaise qu'on
appelle le name and shame mais qui qui
parfois fonctionne quand la loi n'est
pas appliquée aussi et quand on met
quand on stigmatise celles et ceux qui
ne respectent pas les règles c'est
efficace parce que je peux vous dire que
ces entreprises n'aiment pas se
retrouver dans des classements de
mauvais élèves mais donc il y a un
apparatus juridique il y a des décrets
qui ont été pris que nous allons
compléter d'ici la fin de l'année et des
mesures en cours dont nous rendrons
compte en terme de contrôle mais vous
avez raison aujourd'hui les PME sont la
première banque des grands groupes ça ne
peut pas continuer
donc là-dessus il y a des mesures mais
il faut être concret et il faut pouvoir
avancer donc ça fait partie des des
priorités pour ce qui est de de
l'ouverture du capital et de
l'actionnariat salarié monsieur le
sénateur l'objectif c'est en effet
d'avoir une la politique la plus
ambitieuse possible à deux à deux égards
le premier c'est donc l'éparne salariale
pouvoir étendre le dispositif existant
aujourd'hui aux plus petites entreprises
parce qu'il n'était pas une réalité en
particulier pour les moins de 50 et donc
il faut simplifier les règles avoir
aussi des dispositifs plus incitatifs et
trouver les mécanismes financiers qui
protège les salariés parce que je crois
que l'erreur ce serait d'ouvrir le
capital au salariés en leur faisant
courir des risques excessifs et donc
là-dessus il y a aussi des dispositifs
techniques mais importants pour protéger
les salariés de de tout risque le copias
achèvera ses travaux dans une semaine et
nous remettra François repsamen Michel
Sapin et moi-même un rapport l'
l'objectif c'est de pouvoir transcrire
ce rapport dans le projet de loi pour
l'activité et la croissance et donc avec
cette ouverture et la volonté de
d'améliorer le forfait social qui a été
pour des raisons budgétaires largement
augmenté il faut là aussi reconnaître ce
qui a été fait il y a 2 ans et peut-être
de l'aménager dans certaines conditions
pour le rendre plus attractif et
restaurer un peu de son efficacité pour
ce qui est de l'actionnariat salarié je
veux qu'on puisse le travailler sous
deux angles le premier les Bones de
souscription pour créateurs d'entrepris
euh pourquoi parce que les start-ups on
évoque ou les petites entreprises
familiales ce sont des entreprises où
des Françaises et des Français acceptent
de prendre des risques ils acceptte de
prendre un risque il faut bien le dire
qui est supérieur à celui d'un salarié
d'un fonctionnaire parfois d'un élu ou
d'un ministre qui est de mettre leur
capital à risque leur famille à risque
pour créer une entreprise et donc c'est
vrai que il faut reconnaître cette
mobilisation et considérer que ils ont
le droit dans des proportions
explicables et en parfaite transparence
mais d'avoir des mécanismes plus
incitatifs parce qu'on doit récompenser
cette prise de risque parce que
l'économie de demain c'est une économie
de rupture et donc pour y réussir nous
avons besoin de français et de Français
qui prennent des risques et qui prennent
des risques en France et pas à
l'étranger ensuite pour ce qui est des
actions de performance l'idée là c'est
de pouvoir dans les ETI et les grands
groupes avoir un dispositif qui pour les
principaux dirigeants permettent de
récompenser en fonction de la
performance les managers là-dessus il
faut bien le dire nous avons sur le plan
fiscal et pour des raisons qui étaient
politiquement explicables beaucoup
dégradé l'attractivité de ces
instruments comme de celui des stocks
options je crois que les stock options
aujourd'hui ne sont plus attractives il
faut être lucide et il faut pas chercher
à les restaurer je crois qu'il faut que
en même temps qu'on restaure
l'attractivité de ce dispositif qu'on
ait un discours extrêmement éthique à
l'égard des grandes entreprises qui
l'utilisent c'estàd je pense que
l'action et je l'assume l'action de
performance est un bon dispositif pour
l'économie et ça peut être un dispositif
juste quand il est attaché à une
performance qui a été évaluée et c'est
le droit toute entreprise de bien
rémunérer ses dirigeants lorsqu'ils sont
bons parce que si nous considérons que
c'est un interdit dans notre pays les
bons dirigeants ne viendront plus
travailler en France mais de la même
façon on ne peut pas accepter que de
manière automatique on donne des actions
qu'on appelle action de performance
parce que si ça devient automatique ça
n'a plus de sens et lorsque je lis
parfois dans la presse que certains
dirigeants bah touchent des grandes
sommes d'actions gratuites à C certaines
occasions je trouve pas ça satisfaisant
et le message envoyé vient troubler la
cohérence économique qu'on voudrait
porter mais voilà l'esprit en tout cas
dans lequel je le fais le message
général c'est que je pense que notre
économie a besoin de prise de risque et
donc nous devons l'encourager parce que
c'est aussi de la justice sociale parce
que c'est une c'est différent du
salariat et en même temps on sera
d'autant plus crédible que nous traitons
les problèmes de rente ce qui est la
transition à votre dernière question
monsieur le sénateur je reviendrai sur
les autres sur les retraites chapeau
parce que la retraite chapeau c'est
l'exemple type pour le point que je veux
que nous puissions traiter de la rente
en économie alors qu'est-ce qu'on
appelle retraite chapeau parce que c'est
un terme qui n'existe pas en réalité
c'est un terme journalistique il y a des
retraites supplémentaire la retraite
supplémentaire s'explique par le fait
qu'on a capé à H fois le plafond de la
sécurité sociale les cotisations ces
retraites supplémentaires qui sont
souvent par capitalisation s'agit pas de
les interdire elles touchent plusieurs
millions de Français elles sont d'as
pour la plart inférieur à 10000 € tout à
fait raisonnable et ce sont des
retraites pour lesquelles les Françaises
et les Français qui les touch ont cotisé
donc pardon d'être trivial on va pas
massacrer des Françaises et des Français
qui ont cotisé pour leur retraite ce cré
une instabilité
draisonnable par contre voilà le
problème ce sont les sombréros et les
sombrér qu'est-ce que c'est c'est un
chapeau qui est très grand et qu'en plus
vous ne payez pas c'est ça le problème
ce sont les régimes de retraite pour
certains mandatairs sociaux ou cadres
dirigeants
où le dirigeant ne paye pas ou quasiment
pas mais voit l'entreprise provisionner
des montants importants pour lui payer
et ça c'est une forme de rente quand
même si on utilise les gros mots ça
n'est pas généralement corrélé à une
performance alors le code affep medf
auquel nous nous sommes dans un premier
temps rangé implique des règles de
stabilité dans entreprise qui fait que
le par exemple dans le cas de Monsieur
Varin il avait déclaré que ça n'était
pas conforme à ses règles parce qu'il
avait constitué une retraite chapeau de
manière trop rapide dans d'autres cas
considérer que par exemple la retraite
chapeau de monsieur mestralé était
conforme au code parce qu'elle s'était
faite dans la
durée ce qui est vrai donc il s'agit pas
pour l'État qui en septembre 2011 ça
n'était pas ce gouvernement mais en
septembre 2011 l'État a approuvé la
retraite chapeau de Gérard Mestral comme
de plusieurs centaines d'autres membres
de GDF sues je considère que ça n'est
pas responsable
cont tenu de la continuité de l'État et
du message qu'on veut envoyer que l'état
d'un seul coup parce qu'il y a une
polémique disent la retraite chapeau de
Gérard mest n'est plus acceptable ça je
pense que nous ne devons pas le faire
parce qu'on crée une instabilité en
général parce qu'à ce moment-là
n'importe qui dans le monde économique
se dira au gré d'un changement de
majorité d'une polémique les droits
acquis que l'État s'était engagé à faire
et remise en cause par contre notre
devoir c'est de nous poser la question
pour maintenant et pour le futur et donc
notre esprit de responsabilité qui est
de ne pas créer si je puis dire de
remise en cause de ce qui a été
décidé doit aller de paire avec la
lucidité que nous venons de partager et
l'esprit de responsabilité qui est de ne
pas reconstituer ces situations pour le
futur et donc je pense que pour ces
catégories très particulières de
Françaises et de français nous devons
retrouver un régime de droit commun
c'est-à-dire qu'on peut pas demander à
une entreprise à ses salariés de
provisionner pour un ou quelques
dirigeants sans qu'il a contribution
sans donc ça av rien à voir avec la
contribution de ces dirigeants pour
avoir une retraite à vie je vais vous
dire je pense que notre économie
gagnerait à ce qu'on favorise davantage
la performance le succès la réussite de
ces chefs d'entreprise parfois en
acceptant de les payer mieux d'où la
logique des Bones souscription de part
de créateurs d'entreprise et d'action de
performance mais de ne pas leur donner
des espèces de fausses compensation avec
des rentes qui sont malsine voilà donc
c'est l'esprit la cohérence de ces deux
mesures que je voulais mettre en en
relation c'est l'esprit en tout cas de
ce que je proposerai aux uns et aux
autres mais donc je pense qu'il faut là
qu'on y aille clairement sur les
retraites chapeau il y a une hypocrisie
quelque part mais c'est on a été en même
temps raisonnable jusqu'àors de part et
d'autres faut bien le dire on a traité
le problème par la fiscalité donc les
retraites chapeau on a en plus la double
peine c'est que vous avez le coût
politique avec des montants exorbitants
et en réalité celles et ceux qui les
touchent sont fiscalisé à 70 %. donc le
mieux c'est d'arrêter avec ce système
c'est plus propre pour ce qui est du
cice je resturai les chiffres une cice à
lui seul n'est pas de 40 milliards c'est
le pacte de responsabilité c'estice ce
qui sont de 40 milliards sur les 3 ans à
venir il y a eu un rapport parlementaire
qui a été fait sur le cice une
évaluation conduite par le Commissariat
général à la prospective qui ont montré
que c'était aujourd'hui un instrument
que les entreprises dont les entreprises
s'étaient saisies qui marchaient qui
fonctionné y compris à commencé par les
petites et moyennes entreprises il y a
c'est dit moins clairement dans ces de
rapport moi j'ai eu un rapport des
éléments très intéressants des experts
comptables les entreprises qui ne
prennent pas le cice trop souvent c'est
parce qu'elles ont peur du contrôle
fiscal et donc il faut expliquer aux
entreprises que le cice ça n'est pas le
Crédit d'Impôt Recherche et qu'il n'y a
pas de contrôle fiscal attaché au cice
parce que ça n'est pas non c'est la
vérité alors il y a des contrôles
fiscaux en France mais mais donc ça peut
tomber dessus parce que toutes les
entreprises qui sont à les sont sont
soumises au cice même celle qui ne paye
pases mais la vérité c'est que vous
déclarez de la masse salariale avec un
plafond donc donc c'est pas un objet de
de planification de votre contrôle
fiscal donc je crois que il faut que ça
continue à à marcher mais quel était
l'objectif du CCE est derrière du PACT
de responsabilité et de de solidarité
qui décline des allègements de charges
et d'impôts sur 3 ans c'est pas de tirer
tout vers le bas c'est en situation
d'urgence qui est celle de notre
économie française restaurer les marges
des entreprise pourquoi en 2012 quelle
était la situation de notre économie et
là très honnêtement je fais pas de
polémique la réalité dans laquelle nous
nous vivions c'était des marges
historiquement basses pourquoi parce que
nous avons le système de charg de
fiscalité que nous connaissons qui est
le système
français la dynamique salariale des 10
dernières années en France avait été
nettement supérieure à la dynamique
salariale allemande si je compare nous
nous étions mal spécialisés sur le plan
économique et nos entreprises étaient
insuffisamment montées en gamme la vraie
compétitivité c'est la compétitivité
hors coût hein c'est monter en gamme
innover être sur les bons secteurs où on
peut justement trouver les bons clients
et les faire payer cher et constamment
innover dans beaucoup de secteurs nous
n'avons pas su prendre cette
spécialisation l'automobile est un bon
exemple on s'est mis sur le moyen de
gamme qui s'est beaucoup plus fait
comprimer les marges et et et qui a été
victime de la concurrence des États à
Bakou là où les Allemands ont su monter
en gamme et mieux s'organiser mais
restaurer votre compétitivité hors coût
votre politique d'innovation ça prend du
temps ça prend 5 à 10 ans c'est la
réalité et vous n'innovez pas vous
n'investissez pas lorsque vous n'avez
plus de marge donc nous avons fait une
politique en deux temps prendre des
initiatives pour l'innovation et le
développement et l'investissement dès le
début la préservation et même
l'augmentation du crédit impô recherche
qui est un bon instrument va dans ce
sens toutes les initiatives qui ont été
prises dans le cadre d'ailleurs du pacte
de compétitivité des novembre 2012 vont
en ce sens mais l'urgence c'était de
restaurer les marges des entreprises
pour qu'elles puissent embaucher
investir CCE puis le PACT et donc la
dynamique c'est pour ça qu'il est
important qu'il y ait ces négociations
de branche c'est que cet argent soit
utilisé à cet effet et là je veux ici
envoyer un message de
responsabilité la responsabilité du
patronat c'est de conduire ses
négociations de branche moi je suis
préoccupé et déçu de voir que le
patronat continue chaque semaine à avoir
une nouvelle idée fiscale plutôt que
d'organiser les négociations de branche
auxquelles il s'est engagé si on veut
que la France réussisse ça ne marchera
pas sans ces négociations de branche qui
consiste à dire on a le CIC on a le PACT
alors certes c'est très difficile il y a
d'autres choses il y a des branches pour
lesquelles c'est plus difficile que
d'autres mais voilà comment on le
mobilise voilà quelle transparence on
donne à l'action qui est faite comment
on se mobilise sur les apprentis comment
on se mobilise sur l'investissement sur
le développement toutes ces mesures
elles sont importantes pour la
démocratie sociale elles sont aussi un
facteur de compétitivité mais au-delà de
ça on peut mettre tout l'argent qu'on
veut sur les marges des entreprises si
nous répétons nos erreurs passées ça ne
marchera pas parce que nos erreurs
passées qu'est-ce que c'est c'est une
préférence
française pour l'augmentation des
salaires et des dividendes c'est ça la
France des 15 dernières années c'est que
si je compare la France à l'Allemagne
nous avons beaucoup plus augmenté les
salaires de ceux qui avaient un emploi
parce qu'on a préféré augmenter les
salaires qu'embaucher je tiens un
discours macroéconomique mais c'est la
réalité des chiffres et donc si le cice
se transfère intégralement alors qu'il
n'y a pas d'inflationon a une situation
du en augmentation
salariale en 3 4 ans le cice on pe on se
reposera la même question les marches
sont toujours aussi basses parce qu'on
les aura mangé utement et si ces
allgements de charge passent en
politique de dividende ce qu'on a fait
beaucoup plus que les Allemands dans la
période de crise pourquoi parce que
quand on est une familiale on accepte en
période de crise de moins distribué ce
que les entreprises françaises n'ont pas
fait elles ont continué à distribuer
plus que les allemandes pendant cette
période en particulier les financières
hors de crise et donc si on réplique nos
erreurs passées si on ne change pas
collectivement de mentalité de dynamique
et donc qu'on ne recrée pas une forme de
Pact productif dans l'entreprise qui est
de dire on crée plus de transparence on
associe les salariés davantage à la
discussion parce que vous savez quoi
quand on associe les gens à la
discussion ils sont souvent plus
détendus et on est collectivement plus
intelligent au niveau de la branche au
niveau de l'entreprise et on met de la
transparence et on utilise cet argent et
ces nouvelles marches pour investir et
employer on aura fait un grand pas pour
ce qui est des prudomes les il y a une
concertation qui est en cours avec les
syndicats l'esprit du paritarisme sera
préservé
mais on peut faire du paritarisme en
étant plus efficace parce que
l'efficacité est bonne pour les petits
et moyennes entreprises et elle est
bonne pour les salariés les plus
fragiles et je pense que sur ce sujet
c'est important de concerter avec les
syndicats c'est important de concerter
avec les organisations patronales c'est
notre responsabilité de trouver la
meilleure organisation et la décision
autant je crois à la démocratie sociale
autant je pense que la démocratie
sociale elle ne doit pas empêcher les
décideur politique quel qu'ils soit de
prendre leur responsabilité c'est notre
responsabilité de réformer les prudomes
et donc c'est pas un sujet qu'on doit
laisser uniquement aux organisations
syndicales et patronales elles elles
sont au cœur de son fonctionnement elles
seront toujours au cœur de son
fonctionnement mais c'est à nous de le
réformer je ferai des propositions en ce
sens enfin la BCE ce que vous me dites
est miel mais le problème c'est que il y
a un débat vous savez la BCE fait partie
de ces c'est un peu comme l'affaire
drefus en France il y a peu plus d'un
siècle en ont-ils parlé ou pas quand on
se quand on interroge les responsables
économiques ou les grands
décideurs pour que ça marche il faut pas
en parler trop ce que vous dites c'est
ce que la
BCE peut faire et doit faire du
quantitativising comme on dit
c'est-à-dire du non réglementaire et en
effet alors que ça n'est pas
l'interprétation majoritaire des traités
peut acheter de la dette des états
souverain ce qui serait un instrument
extrêmement efficace de création
monétaire et qui aurait un impact
macroéconomique pour pour notre économie
pour nos économies la réalité c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de consensus
au sein du Conseil des
gouverneurs ma conviction profonde c'est
que Mario dragi réfléchit à cela qu'il y
a aujourd'hui une prise de conscience
croissante qui a un besoin de demande au
sein de la zone euro et donc un besoin
d'un choc macro-économique qui soit
d'une autre nature que ce qu'on envage
ma conviction c'est qu'on arrivera à
déclencher cela non pas en le demandant
avec force en mettant sous pression la
BCE mais en créant les conditions
politiques pour que la BCE puisse
décider de la sorte
c'est-à-dire la France en faisant ses
réformes et en montrant que elle
construit elle-même son avenir
économique et politique et l'Europe en
prenant ses responsabilités et donc en
trouvant un compromis politique sur un
vrai plan d'investissement pour l'Europe
si les états continuent à montrer qu'il
manquent de leadership qui ne veulent
pas se décider et qui ne se mettent pas
d'accord la BCE consuera considérera
très vraisemblablement que les
conditions politiques de son interven ne
sont pas réunies je n'oublie pas qu'en
juillet 2012 lorsque Mario Dragui a pris
cette décision a fait cette déclaration
extrêmement forte qui a calmer le feu
qu'il y avait dans la zone euro il l'a
fait parce que en juin 2012 sous
l'impulsion du Président François
Hollande les gouvernement de la zone
euro ont su trouver un accord pour
préserver l'intégrité de celle-ci s'il
n'y avait pas eu ce geste politique en
premier je pense qu'on devra on rendra
historiquement la France son rôle en
juin 2012 parce que nous avons beaucoup
utilisé notre crédit politique
post-élection à la SAU à la sauvegarde
de la zone euro s'il n'y avait pas eu ce
ce momentum politique il n'y aurait pas
eu cette décision de de la BCE enfin euh
pour ce qui est
euh des dernières questions que je n'ai
pas traité euh deux remarques et ce
faisant je les ai oublié et je vous pris
en excuser donc je je crois que c'était
Jo
Joë concernant les M lié à la
énergétique et à la transition
trans oui alors sur la transition
énergétique donc il y a différentes
initiatives qui sont pris sur ces
métiers de deux ordres un dans la loi
transition énergétique avec des éléments
sur la qualification et les
investissements qui sont mis en place
face à ces derniers donc il y a des
mécanismes d'incitation à la fois pour
l'offre et la demande qui sur la
rénovation thermique sont extrêmement
important et je l'espère seront votés en
tout cas c'est un des éléments de
relance dans ce secteur qui est
fondamental et deuxème point c'est un
secteur qui occupe aujourd'hui deux
plans industriels dans lesquels nous
avons mis pour mieux structurer l'offre
là aussi de l'argent et dans lesquel
nous avons investi et aujourd'hui le P2
a plus de de 12 milliards d'euros de
crédit qui contribu justement à la
transition écologique et énergétique
donc c'est une priorité qui est sur la
rénovation thmique et les travaux qu'on
vient d'évoquer mais qui est aussi surt
le secteur des transports de la mobilité
durable donc je crois à la fois sur la
politique industrielle et la
politique écologique c'est une priorité
dans lequelle on met de l'argent public
du côté de la demande et du côté de
l'offre parce que il faut bien le dire
aussi c'est dans ce secteur et Carole
vous en dira deux mots je pense que nous
arriverons à retrouver de l'activité
pour le BTP parce que s'il y a bien un
levier de croissance pour bâtiments et
travaux publics il sera dans la
rénovation thermique et dans ces
nouveaux
métiers faut je bien monsieur le
ministre vous nous aviez accordé un
lapse de temps qui est largement
consommé donc même si d'autres collègu
aurait souhaité intervenir il n'est
malheureusement plus possible de le
faire j'ai déjà prévenu Caro Delga que
nous avions là en revanche plus de
laattitude jusqu'à 21h donc il y a pas
de problème donc nous pourrons continuer
je vous demande quelques instant voilà
pour cette audition d'Emmanuel Macron le
ministre de l'économie qui a donc été
auditionné par les sénateur de la
commission des affaires économiques
présidé par l'UMP Jean-Claude Lenoir il
a été interrogé notamment sur les crédit
de son ministère par le pour le projet
de loi de finances 2015 mais vous avez
pu l'entendre lors de cette audition le
ministre est notamment longuement revenu
sur la réforme qui s'annonce sa réforme
des professions réglementées qui visent
notamment et bien les notaires les
huussiers les avocats il a notamment et
bien largement développer l'exemple des
notaires expliquant combien il voulaient
faciliter l'accès à cette profession
rappelons que le projet de loi de
finances pour 2015 a été adopté hier en
première lecture par l'Assemblée
nationale et qu'il va être examiné à
partir de demain au Sénat en séance
publique tout de suite je vous propose
de revenir à une autre audition de la
commission des affaires économiques du
Sénat une audition qui s'est déroulée un
petit peu plus tôt dans l'après-midi
celle de l'économiste Jean Tirol
également pris Nobel d'économie à
l'invitation que je lui ai adressé une
fois connue euh